[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler finit pas
muraire économistes vous est à classer
dans la famille on va dire des
souverainistes pour vous situer bonsoir
philippe huerre merci d'être avec nous a
ajouté françois pour les mathis
journaliste spécialiste des institutions
européennes
bonsoir à vous et merci d'être là
françois paul et mathis et emmanuel
macron a donc reconnu des quoi car hier
soir l'europe est un peu un deal zèle en
matière de vaccination a avoué à demi le
président français je vous propose de
l'écouter avant de vous faire réagir
on n'a pas pensé que ça irait aussi vite
la recherche en europe s'est faite
beaucoup d'ailleurs de la recherche
mondiale sur les vaccins vient d'europe
les américains us ont eu un mérite d'été
2020 ils ont dit on met le paquet et on
y va
et donc ils ont plus ils ont eu plus
d'ambition que nous et le quoi qu'il en
coûte qu'on a appliqué pour les mesures
d'accompagnement eux l'ont impliqué pour
les vaccins la recherche
le mérite en tout cas du mea culpa
philippe murray rôle c'est dans une
famille quand il ya des problèmes on a
tendance un petit peu à se rejeter la
faute c'est ce qui risque de se passer
lors de ce sommet ce soir on risque de
se faire quelques reproches je crois pas
que l'union européenne d'une famille
d'ailleurs vous on parle de l'europe
mais l'europe on parle pas du continent
européen qui peut survivre ou pas les
pays européens survivre ou forcément
l'union européenne c'est la machine
bureaucratique qui est au dessus des
états nations historiques de la france
de l'allemagne de l'italie de l'espagne
et qui en serre et qui est administré
une administration tout simplement
effectivement il ya des ratés depuis le
début en fait il ya un an y avait pas de
masse parce qu'on avait de localiser les
usines à cause de l'union européenne pas
de gel hydroalcoolique parce que l'union
européenne est ouvert à tous les vents
elle aidait tout ça était partie en asie
il ya un an s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait pas dit dre une animation pas à ça
et qu'on a laissé des gens mourir parce
que l'union européenne avait à 67
reprise demandé aux pays d'europe entre
2011 et 2018
selon un chef de groupe du parlement
européen de quelqu'un d'important au
parlement européen de privatiser des
pans entiers de la santé publique et de
réduire les dépenses de santé donc
l'europe est extrêmement fait beaucoup
de mal
en fait au système de santé public elle
a été incapable de commander les vaccins
même sa stratégie parce que la stratégie
des vaccins genre spatiaux qu'elle soit
intelligente parce que les vaccins
est-ce qu'ils protégeront les gens des
variantes ou pas ça on n'en sait rien on
n'en est pas sûr du tout en tout cas ce
qu'on sait c'est que c'était la
stratégie de l'union européenne
annonçait une stratégie complètement
ratée parce que l'europe est un attelage
encombrants peu manoeuvrant et qu'en
fait du coup elle à elle à vacciner
trois fois moins de gens que les
américains feront moins que les rues
droit les outils qui a eu bien raison de
sortir de l'union européenne il est
beaucoup plus agile beaucoup plus véloce
et pour finir sur des vaccins
ça me français on va on va le voir
distribuer la parole pardonnez-moi
philippe mes horaires vous aurez
l'occasion de le dire
françois pour les médecins gala merkel
dit aussi évidemment qui a eu des ratés
à tel point que la chancelière allemande
ça ne lui ressemble pas vraiment à
lancer une forme d'avertissement et elle
dit en clair que si ça ne l'est pas plus
vite
elle prendrait les choses en main
comprendre on va agir seuls dans notre
coin nous les allemands comme l'a dit
philippe murray la santé c'est un
domaine qu'on ne peut pas mettre en
commun au sein de l'europe selon vous
ont scié juste mal pris il faut préciser
que la santé la politique de 100 parties
des politiques communautaires et donc
l'europe très opportunément a finalement
essayé de réagir suite à cette pandémie
pour trouver une solution pour avoir une
réaction commune dans un domaine où elle
n'est pas compétente a priori donc ça
c'est une nouveauté est ce que l'europe
a été à la hauteur non n'a pas été à la
hauteur ça c'est clair
par contre l'acte 1 de sa décision a été
une bonne décision
cette bonne décision ça a été de décider
de négocier ensemble groupé
des contrats pour obtenir des vaccins et
non pas chacun séparément
on sait très bien ce que ça aurait pu
donner si chaque pays avait pris
séparément sa propre politique les
négociations avec ça il en aurait
résulté peut-être pour certains pays
effectivement d'avoir été un peu plus à
la hauteur mais pour d'autres pays
d'être totalement dépendants je suis pas
persuadé que pour la france elle soit
sorti de manière favoriser d'une
situation où chacun aurait été mieux que
chacun pour soi dans la mesure où la
france n'a pas d'industrie de vaccins et
la france elle même avait une très forte
en bâtissant son souvient la réticence
de la population française au vaccin
donc on risque et nous peut-être encore
un peu plus en retard qu'on ne l'a été
alors c'est vrai l'europe n'a pas été la
hauteur mais elle a néanmoins réussi une
chose qui est essentiel qui est de
mettre en commun sa stratégie qui pour
l'instant n'est pas convaincante mais
qui pourrait le devenir demain parce que
la sphère n'est pas fini le prix des
vignes
je suis au début oui les i parce que
c'est vrai que françois pour les valises
marque un poids si je peux me permettre
parce que c'est vrai qu'en france on n'a
pas de vaccin mais non mais c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas de vaccin est bon qu'est
ce qu'on aurait fait de plus en gardons
notre stratégie souveraineté sur ce pôle
avait une stratégie industrielle
le problème c'est qu'on a à la fois
l'union européenne qui est un problème
les maquereaux et européiste et qui veut
tout faire à travers l'union européenne
et il le dit tout le temps qui est un
problème parce que on à sanofi en à
pasteur et on aurait pu pousser ces
entreprises vraiment à faire un accent
de l'est vous savez qu'on avait un wagon
dont il y avait un vaccin très bas à
c'est moins qu'au royaume uni aux états
unis et il y avait valu à l'entreprise
nantaise qui est très intéressante qui a
développé un vrai mac sans ce programme
c'est pas des vaccins
c'est d injection de code génétique
notamment les kaizer évident et c'est
pour ça que les gens sont pareils l'est
var a lancé une étude pour un vaccin
inactivé classique on aurait accepté
beaucoup plus facilement il y aurait
aucun problème aujourd'hui de confiance
dans ces vaccins tels qu'on a
aujourd'hui
orval neymar l'union européenne ne l'a
pas aidé et en fait la france n'a pas
aidé au nom plus européistes ma grande
va pas aider
en fait c'est le royaume uni qui agile
qui pensent souveraine des firmes
industrielles qui pensera
j industriel qui a donné de l'argent
avec des accents et qui va avoir 60
millions de doses de vaccins inactivés
si ça se passe bien
cette année alors que l'union européenne
et même la france c'est vous rendez
compte
le ca aurait permis de donner de la
confiance à la population jusque c'est
d'un vaccin inactivé classique alors que
les gens sont quand même très réticent à
s'injecter des codes génétiques
alors que ce sont des vaccins je
rappelle enfin ce code génétique en
essai clinique sommes en lice écrit les
gens s'énervent déco heureusement oui
françois pour les mathis allez allez on
est face à un problème d'urgence il faut
bien comprendre qu'on n'est pas dans une
solution ou pour prendre son temps pour
essayer de voir qui est la meilleure
solution
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est prendre les
vaccins tels qu'ils existent et non pas
d'espérer des vaccins qui ne sont pas
encore sur le marché et les vaccins qui
existent actuellement il y en a trois
peut-être un quatrième qui va arriver et
c'est les seuls sur lequel on peut
compter
qui aurait pu imaginer d'obtenir ce qui
va arriver une augmentation très
substantielle notamment des vaccins
pfizer qui vont arriver en doses
beaucoup plus importante dans l'est dans
les semaines qui viennent
grâce à une négociation au niveau
européen autre chose que fait-on par
rapport aux ratés du vaccin à seneca qui
n'a pas tenu ses promesses
seule l'europe est en mesure de faire
pression sur les entreprises sur
astrazeneca pour obliger cette
entreprise finalement à en respecter ses
engagements et donc voyez bien
saône-et-loire françois paul et matisse
mais vous ayez dette c'est compliqué
vous nous dites il faut agir dans
l'urgence il faut prendre ce qu'il ya
mais on ne prend pas ce qui a regardé
les russes ont tendu la main aux
européens ça met des mois et des mois
alors je me doute qu'il ya du travail
mais enfin c'est quand même très lents
comme rythme pour aller certifier un
vaccin alors c'est pas vrai on prend
parce qu'il ya le temps que tout le
monde se mette d'accord cela mes 17 ans
quand on prend ce qu'il y a le problème
c'est que les vaccins ne sont pas là les
vaccins ne sont pas là ils ça c'est pas
le problème de l' or c'est le problème
des entreprises qui n'arrivent pas à
suivre le rythme mais parfois c'est
aussi long de djeddah de valider un
vaccin johnson & johnson a été validée
en étant toujours scouts nick est en
cours de validation ça m'est vraiment
longtemps non oui ou non vous êtes bien
qu il ya des garanties
actuellement l'europe à négocier ces
vaccins avec un minimum de garanties
faut savoir par exemple que pour le
vaccin russe qui a été accepté puisqu'il
est il a été ratifié donc il peut être
utilisé en europe
le problème c'est que qu'arrive-t-il en
cas de pépin qu'arrive-t-il en cas
d'effets secondaires qui serait un petit
peu gênant pour un certain nombre de
vaccins la garantie juridique n'est pas
là l'europe a négocié une garantie
juridique qui permet finalement à toutes
les entreprises de s'engager à être
responsable juridiquement des
conséquences de tout à 6 ans sur le
vaccin
ça fait partie aussi des sécurité de
base que l'europe a des contrats c'est
justement le merrer je voulais vous
servir non justement la sécurité
juridique
selon le canard enchaîné les
commissaires européens ont tardé à
conclure des contrats avec les labos car
il voulait absolument avoir une clause d
protégeant personnellement de tout
procès sur les vaccins ce que les
anglais les américains et les israéliens
n'auraient pas demandé justement cette
sécurité juridique cette bureaucratie
est ce que c'est là que le bât blesse
c'était une sécurité juridique pour eux
tout seul parce que peut-être monsieur
poulet mathis a raison mais c'est la
première fois que j'entends dire que les
fabricants de vaccins sont responsables
en cas d'effets secondaires
j'ai lu exactement l inverse depuis six
mois par tous donc que en fait c'étaient
les états qui seraient responsables si
avec des effets secondaires et puis
alors quelle sécurité
vous avez vu que l' agence européenne du
béton
gamme en a réautorisé le vaccin
astrazeneca qui fait des thromboses
apparemment chez les jeunes et là on a
du coup la france la ré autorisé en
suivant comme un caniche nain agence
européenne du médicament qui pourront
pourtant un repaire de lobbyistes et je
vais en parler tout de suite c'est alors
que l'autorité de santé bien dire la
haute autorité de santé française vient
de dire en fait il ya des vrais risques
avec le astrazeneca pour les jeunes pour
les thromboses il y a beaucoup de
thrombose donc là on est en alerte
il n'y a aucune sécurité juridique
l'agencé européenne du médicament est un
repère de lobbyistes de gens qui
viennent des lobbys pharmaceutiques mais
carrément ils sont engagés par les
oublis sable pharmaceutique plus tard il
devient directeur de l'agencé européenne
du médicament
ou alors il son directeur de l'agencé
européenne du médicament ils deviennent
lobbyistes la directrice générale
aujourd'hui et mr troupe vient du lobby
de big pharma
c'est sans doute pour ça qu'ils ont
autorisé des médicaments pas efficaces
contre le coc vident leurs md sivir qui
vaut très cher de gilles ead les
anticorps monoclonaux qui ne sont
d'aucune preuve d'efficacité qui sont
très chers et de tester on ne les
connaît pas et elles ont refusé tous les
traitements pas cher le protocole raoult
l'azithromycine aussi qui marche très
bien sur les médecins qu'il utilise est
aussi bien sûr l'ivermectine qui est
selon l'om a sans danger utilisable à
grande échelle
tous les médecins qui l'utilisent dit
que c'est formidable c'est utilisé au
mexique en inde dans tout un tas paix
dans une vingtaine de pays
et ça marche très très bien les études
montrent que c'est diviser par quatre la
mortalité dont on est dans un repaire de
lobbyistes là il pourrait y croiser
procès contre l'agencé européenne du
médicament pour les mettre 600 en
revient à notre question initiale de
débats ce que l'europe peut survivre à
cette pandémie est ce qu'il y aura un
avant et un après qui nécessitera au
moins une sacrée réforme parce que les
populations risquent voilà on n'est pas
au bout de nos peines malheureusement
les populations risque d'avoir quelques
rancunes si elles ne sont pas vaccinés
que les états unis redémarre la chine
israël etc
j'avais les crises en europe c'est pas
la première
il y en a eu beaucoup et au général
l'europe se construit sur l'écrit c'est
ça qui est paradoxal c'est au travers
des crises que l'europe sait se
fortifier la dernière crise on l'a vu
avec le bris si tout le monde prédisait
un éclatement de l'europe
finalement le break chiite a eu pour
conséquence de ressouder entre les pays
d'europe
on l'a vu aussi au moment des crises
financières ou l'europe a su inventer
des méthodes et notamment des méthodes
qui permettent de d'emprunter de
l'argent de manière collective et non
pas de manière individuelle
on l'a vu dans l'histoire à 2,36 moment
au nom de l'élargissement ou il a fallu
trouver des solutions pour décider avec
plus grande efficacité où on a introduit
le vote à la majorité pour éviter une
solution une paralysie impossible
françois pour les métiers c'est ce que
la population va suivre parce que si
tout le monde se met à voter pour des
partis très souverainiste et
eurosceptique ça va fragiliser l europe
et le royaume uni est bien parti oui
mais l'europe et peut toujours être
fragilisé toujours est il que l'europe
regardez ce qui se passe au niveau des
partis politiques y compris en france où
vous voyez les partis politiques comme
le rassemblement national qui était
d'une certaine manière très s'ouvrit ce
à une époque et on a vu madame marine le
pen qui aujourd'hui abandonne l'idée de
remettre en cause l'euro abandonne
l'idée de remettre en cause
l'appartenance à l'union européenne et
donc finalement les partis qui ont une
prétention un peu importante sur le plan
national
eux mêmes se rendre compte que aller
contre l'europe c'est aller contre la
nature aller contre l'évidence et donc
je crois simplement que les gens se
rendront compte et on le voit bien sur
le plan sanitaire sortir de cette crise
on n'en sortira pas seul pays isolé un
parent ne peuvent pas sentir seul on
doit être groupe et ça c'est clair
philippe merle le mot de la fin pour
l'économiste que vous êtes parce qu'à
aussi l'aspect économique on le verra
avec jacques saint-pierre dans quelques
instants
le retard pris par ce calendrier
vaccinal nous coûte apparemment à
l'europe 123 milliards d'euros
c'est ce qu'estime aujourd'hui
l'assureur crédit euler hermes pendant
ce temps effectivement les ayez à
d'autres pays qui vont redémarrer
et redémarrer plus fort plus vite ça va
beaucoup nous pénaliser nous autres
européens
oui deux choses qui vont nous pénaliser
vous avez raison la première chose c'est
que l'europe en fait à une très mauvaise
politique l'union européenne a une très
mauvaise politique et la zone euro à 7 %
de récession quand les états unis ont
deux fois moins de récession donc on est
le pays qui s'en sort déjà les pays s'en
sortent le moins du monde on est comme
d'habitude de toute manière le trou noir
de la présence mondiale
ça fait vingt ans que ça dure deuxième
chose le plan de relance européen et
cinq fois plus faible que le plan de
relance chinois et américains donc ça va
être catastrophique parce qu'on
redémarre à beaucoup moins vite à la
fois plus tard à cause des vaccins est
beaucoup moins vite parce que le plan de
relance est beaucoup trop petit beaucoup
trop saupoudré beaucoup trop étalé dans
le temps
il est mal fait comme tout ce que touche
l'union européenne et donc ça va mal se
passer
moi je finirai en nous disant est ce qu
est ce que l'europe survivre à la crise
j'espère que l'europe l'union européenne
ne survivra pas la crise la machine
bureaucratique européenne parce que
sinon c'est la france qui continuera un
déclin sans fin un déclin qui est là
depuis dix ou quinze ans et les gens le
voient monsieur les gens commencent à
plus pouvoir manger à leur faim
20% des français on peut rêver de
l'europe mais l'europe préparé des 30%
des gens qui ne se soignent plus parce
qu'ils n'ont pas assez d'argent 1
millions de pauvres en plus dans cette
crise est le problème grenat de toute
manière charles de gaulle l'avait très
bien dit la démocratie pour moi se
confond exactement avec la souveraineté
nationale la machine bureaucratique
européenne piquant la souveraineté
nationale la démocratie est l'intérêt de
la soul du vote populaire disparaît
c'est toujours les mêmes politiques
économiques et même politiques qui sont
conduites et la démocratie est
malheureusement en train de disparaître
de plus en plus rendez-vous dans un an
et on verra qui a raison et bien rendez
vous dans un an
rendez vous pris en tout cas deux
opinions différentes l intérêt des
face-à-face merci à tous les deux
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france